let's say you had one minute less than
two minutes to go ahead and talk with
him what would you throw at him what
would you say to him to go ahead and
plant some kind of seed what would you
say I would just ask him one thing I
would say see everything that we acquire
in this life will stay behind accept
your investment and those things that
are transferable to the next life and I
tell you right now and I promise you
right now that that investment that
Sarah investing in a Masjid in the mega
dawa Center the dean Center is something
that will inshallah be transferable and
bless you in this life in the next so do
your small part do your major part we
are going to move forward as we've been
moving forward this far we've acquired
the property now it's time to get it up
and running so we need your help to make
this a reality click the link below
donate right now may God Almighty Allah
reward all of you
foreign
[Music]
let's see what he had to say because we
opened up talking a little bit about him
so the last time he came on the scene he
went in back and forth on the Twitter
with the Muslim regarding the Hellfire
and he talked about something along the
lines that if most people are going to
end up in the Hell Fire he wouldn't mind
being there also something like that but
then recently some's come up that he's
actually
talking a different tune so how would
you invite him give him some doubt do
you believe in like a god or like a
higher power well something created the
universe or the universe is
you know here how did it come to be
um you could say whatever course the
universe to come to be is God or
you know God's depending on your view um
philosophy I think makes sense is to go
out there and is to expand Consciousness
so that we're better under better able
to to answer the questions of like what
is the meaning of life what is the
nature of the universe like how do
molecules have Consciousness but somehow
we're from a bunch of hydrogen gas
to and then an assemblage of complex
molecules like ourselves that can feel
and talk and and think I mean just if
you leave hydrogen out long enough it
starts talking to itself basically it's
what happened here so what do you think
no I mean see this is
trying to understand now that he's
agreeing that there is a power there is
a God who created the universe so this
is where dawa plays the role it is the
it is the duty of the Muslims to explain
to him who that God is who that power is
who created the universe so now it's our
duty to explain absolutely absolutely
through words yes this is not just
actions here right what how can we show
in actions that God created the universe
yeah you gotta go ahead and you have to
talk talk so now go how what would you
say to him now how would you respond to
Elon Musk definitely the see because
he's a knowledgeable person he has some
scientific understanding though he's not
a scientist but the way he has
contributed to the world doing some
things that can benefit the people
around the world so similarly we need to
have deep concern for him that will
benefit him here in this world and the
akhira and you see this is the secret of
Islam the prophet sallallahu always will
that people like Abu Bakr
um people who are influential in the
society shall become Muslims and that
will be a great support to the cause of
Islam masha'allah so those Brothers I
would congratulate my Muslim brothers
who are in contact with him through
Twitter or whatever means possible for
them now it's the duty of the Muslim
Community who can go approach him talk
to him to set up meetings with Experts
of the field of dawa to talk to him
about it mashallah and I think I would
suggest that you take an interview with
him and that would be really wonderful
mashallah so it's see when you are
speaking you have a background of dawa
so it's not just that you ask questions
or interview somebody you also keep
conveying the visit of Islam to them so
I think if Elon Musk is given the right
book in his hand made to read this book
directly the book will do the job I
always tell the people you see Allah
made the job so easy for us
maximum you have to do is convey this
message the remaining Allah's message
will do what would you do if you if you
have because to get a sit down with
someone like this to get one minute
let's say you had one minute less than
two minutes to go ahead and talk with
him what would you throw at him what
would you say to him to go ahead and
plant some kind of seed what would you
say I would just ask him one thing I
would say see Elon you are so sensible
person just tell me one single thing a
person who lived 1450 years back in a
dessert historical records are saying he
doesn't know how to read and write
Prophet Muhammad didn't know how to read
and write you go to Encyclopedia
Britannica to search about him any other
historical record it's very clear he
didn't know to read and write the Quran
testifies the same Suraj number two
Surah number 157 my Prophet is an um
he's an unlettered Prophet so I would
like to ask a person of that caliber of
Elon Musk that how can this person 1450
years back talk about the big bang that
you're talking about now can science and
religion coexist
probably not
how can it be possible that a person
living in desert where there is no water
scarcity of water miles they travel to
get water he's talking sorry Ambience
do not the disbelievers look at the
heavens and the sky
we joined we they were joined as one
single unit of creation the nebula and
we clothe them Ascender and then Allah
says
we created every life from water the
size to it can you imagine a person who
is totally unless talking about it so
there are so many ayat in the Quran that
will connect Elon Musk and he he will be
pondering because he's a man of science
yes right he's an act he's absolutely
selection there is a book by Morris
bukel yeah who who
came forward to say there are more than
700 ayat of the Quran out of the six
thousand plus ayat in the Quran at least
one thousand he said deals with modern
science and of them 700 plus ayati said
the science has agreed them to be fact
what does it mean at the time of prophet
Muhammad nobody knew about it that
knowledge didn't exist about those
subjects but 700 of them today this tend
to be true not a single scientific error
in the Quran so this is what Elon Musk
shall be
I talked with and maybe I mean it
depends because one minute two minute
that you get it also depends upon his
interaction with us it's very difficult
to say what exactly we are going to
speak to him it totally depends upon
what mood he has at the time yeah so you
have to reflect with that mood
anticipate with that mood and then talk
to him on those lines Which pull his
interest masha'allah yeah that would be
a starting point how this is what you
would go ahead and leave him with to
think about absolutely absolutely and
hopefully if he looks into the life of
absolutely promise you sent to mankind
if he's sincere absolutely looking for
the truth he's asking the Creator to
guide him Allah
and we shall also pray for him yeah see
because Elon Musk Jeff Bezos it's Bill
Gates these people they have done so
much for the society they have been so
much really good for the society but
have you seen that a lot of times people
like him he talks about in his early
years he was a Christian I think his
mother father Jewish Christian and then
he went towards that Avenue as a child
but he saw some things that he'd agree
with yeah also the way of Jesus that was
presented to him a lot of times
yes this position human being rejects a
human being being as God Brad like a
whole bunch of religious books including
the Bible and I'm like there's a bunch
of things now that I'm teaching at
Sunday school yeah God Church changes
his mind
from the Old Testament to the New
Testament I'm like whoa that's pretty
vengeful in the Old Testament so now
what if he comes into Islam looks into
Jesus is rolling in Islam that we love
Jesus he's a mighty messenger just like
Abraham Moses all the other Messengers
but they weren't Gods
absolutely this would fit this would
make sense absolutely see if for a
person like him he's a person of
reasoning yeah so he would reason that
if God is becoming human then he's
leaving all the characters of a God yeah
because if a man converts to a dog
then he leaves all human characters in
him if a man converts to a dog if put it
this way technically put it this way if
a man incarnates as dog yes then that
dog incarnate the man incarnate as dog
will leave all the qualities of human
beings yes once it is a dog it's no more
a human being you cannot call it a human
dog yes so similarly if God becomes a
man then God has lost all his Divine
qualities now because those weaknesses
occur in you not a God man you can't be
a god you cannot so Elon Musk is a very
reasonable person